[Music]
we have the best economy in history when
you hear how great the economy is doing
right now let's just remember when this
recovery started more than four million
jobs created since the election I have
to kind of remind them actually those
job numbers are the same as they were in
2015 in 2016 I think he was time to take
some credit he was trying to take credit
for this incredible thing that's
happening to our country it did not
start with Donald Trump he is a symptom
not because he's just capitalizing on
resentments that politicians have been
Fanning for years I'm sorry I watched it
but I fell asleep I found he's very good
very good for sleeping former President
Obama getting into the campaign swing as
current president Trump responds almost
real-time let's bring in our panel and
start there Jason Reilly Wall Street
Journal columnist and senior fellow at
the Manhattan Institute Molly Hemingway
is senior editor at the Federalist and
Charles Lane opinion writer for The
Washington Post
well you know it was the former
President Obama's first kind of going
out there specifically targeting
president Trump your thoughts on his
message and how that translates well he
might be the best thing that the
Democrats have going for them he's still
extremely popular in the party and and
in the country frankly and he's gonna
give it everything he's got for for the
midterms so I'm not surprised to see him
him do this it is a little bit out of
the norm previous administrations tend
to stay quiet
Obama's chosen not to take that path I
guess it's another example of how all
norms are off the table whether we're
talking about all the media is gonna
treat this president or whether we're
talking about how former presidents are
gonna treat this president politically
well I just want to say that that is an
important point we're told that Donald
Trump is the only person who violates
norms or does anything differently and
we do have a norm in this country that
presidents usually speak well of their
successors you
George W Bush do that through your
silent or their silent George W Bush did
that through all eight years of the
Obama presidency it's an absolutely free
country and people should be free to say
whatever they want but I think a lot of
people noticed that people seem to be
breaking a lot of norms along with
President Trump and the it is good for
the Democrats to have someone like Obama
coming in trying to rally the vote but
in the same way that President Trump
seems to excite both his base and his
opponents the same is absolutely true
for President Obama people in the
Democratic Party love to hear him speak
people in the Republican Party are
reminded why they voted for Donald Trump
or what they didn't like about President
Obama Chuck well you know the catch-22
in a way here for President Obama is
that if he were to go out on the
campaign trail and not mention Donald
Trump no one would be interested because
the whole election is a referendum on
Donald Trump and the most motivating
campaign theme for democratic voters is
resistance to Donald Trump so in a way
there's no point campaigning unless
you're gonna break this long-standing
norm because it's the only issue in the
campaign I tend to agree with I guess
both of my colleagues here that it's
it's possibly a net plus for the
Democrats to have him back out on the
trail particularly among
african-american voters we're gonna be a
key part of their coalition in some of
these southern states so I think I think
he's we're gonna see more of them here
is talking about media I complained
plenty about Fox News but you never
heard me threaten to shut him down or
call them enemies of the people now he
had some interesting lines there Jason
this is not what about ISM it is just
truth his attorney general obviously
called one of our reporters a
co-conspirator James Rosen and a flight
risk and you know that there are
different things here that you know you
kind of have to fact-check we are trying
to fact-check
to the current administration but that
speech there was some interesting
moments well I guess the biggest
pushback I would have to what President
Obama
said was that he didn't have to worry
about criticism coming out of Fox News
because he had every other network in
his pocket for eight years just like
previous Democrats have had so the idea
that he didn't over was an overly
concern of what Fox was saying to the
extent that it was true and as you just
said it's not entirely true when you
have every other major news Oregon in
the country on your side yes you don't
have to worry about these things that
doesn't exclude the enemy of the people
of rhetoric from the president look I
mean coming from a newspaper that's
taken its share of blows fair and unfair
from mostly unfair I would say from this
president I would say what I think
independently what he said about Fox
here and there it is a fact you can look
it up that Barack Obama repeatedly told
audiences that they should read both the
New York Times and The Wall Street
Journal editorial page he said you
should watch this network you should
watch that network you should try and
get both sides you should get outside of
your bubble he told student groups I
believe Howard University was one he he
rebuked them for not permitting certain
controversial speakers he he supported
the idea that conservatives should have
free speech on campus I think we
repeatedly stuck his neck out and so I
don't really think there's any
comparison on that that is not my
recollection at all of the eight years
under at all blamed he blamed many bad
things in the country on people watching
Fox News he claimed it was on every bar
in the country and that's why Democrats
were hurt he tried to freeze out Fox
News in multiple instances he spied on
reporters he's one of the worst
presidents when it comes to actual
actions when it comes to the media
presidents Ronald Ronald president
Donald Trump speaks against freedom of
the press or speaks against the press in
a way that does not live up to what we
would hope to hear in terms of support
of freedom of the press when it comes to
actual actions taken against the media
the Obama administration was bad and the
media didn't care and when Donald Trump
couldn't lightly criticizes the press of
course the music criticizes a boy caught
him they canceled the White House press
they freaked out about the press dinner
and the it is that difference in how
they reacted to criticism by President
Obama toward press
to how they react I believe when Fox was
free frozen out of the White House
Correspondents Brett you checking on
this the rest of the media came to
foster White House pool yes yes yes but
the point is Fox did recently to CNN
correct actual actions taken and
attempts to spy on reporters or go after
them the Obama administration was very
bad and the media didn't have the same
reaction to it that they do to the Trump
administration I want I want to turn
topics really quickly and that is the
president saying that the Attorney
General should be investigating who the
author of this op-ed anonymous op-ed is
Jason no I disagree that the Attorney
General should spend should spend time
doing this Brett I think that the
president is legitimately concerned that
someone supposedly in his inner circle
has has done this it's it's something
I'd be upset about - all of us would but
whether it rises to the level of an
investigation by the Attorney General I
don't I don't think that's the case
we're gonna know but the Attorney
General should be investigating all the
leaks that we have seen from this
administration for two years that go
against the Trump administration and
that's something we haven't even seen
any evidence that there's been any
investigation of the criminal leaking
against Mike Flynn for instance poor
Jeff Sessions cannot kind of get a break
the president just keeps on trolling him
and harassing and giving him more
impossible things to do
although he said he's gonna make it
through the midterms at least here's
what he yes